thank you, ladies and gentlemen, president, almost a
year ago the european union took a
historic step by approving the
european mechanism for recovery and resilience,
which involves a disbursement of 672,000
million euros in loans and
subsidies, it is the oxygen that
so many workers need, so
many companies so many self-employed workers
young people and so many social services that
are currently supporting
those hardest hit by the pandemic, I
believe that our duty here is to ensure
that this money reaches the
people who need it as soon as possible, however, I
would not want to have to think that some in
this chamber  are using this debate
to try to re-incorporate
criteria of macro conditionality and
austerity through the back door if they
really have so much interest in this plan
I would worry more about pressuring
the heads of government and their parties
to carry out parliamentary ratification
of the mechanism to not have kidnapped
and  he future of this fund is an
emergency fund because the situation is an
emergency, perhaps not for some here,
but for millions of families and
companies in our countries when
citizens are asking us to speed up
the pace so that the money from the
deep down nobody would understand that we
are now embroiled in a dispute between
the institutions and that it will delay the
process that could only fuel
euroscepticism and disaffection with
europe let us take advantage of this
recovery fund to gain the trust
of the Europeans and
we Europeans cannot allow the pressures
Some internal groups call into
question the management of this crisis, which
is a management very different from that of
2008, the socialists and democrats will
always defend the responsibility
of parliament in economic governance
that the funds be used to
undertake profound reforms that make
the union  European Union adapts to the
challenges and the challenges that these have
for their  since if we socialists and
democrats accept all the debates
we will all continue talking and negotiating
but we will not be distracted from what
really matters and that is to press for
ratification in the
national parliaments and we are already working on the
adoption of the technical criteria for
the  social spending, but what we need
is collective leadership, institutional loyalty,
and the ability to forge
majorities, because here, without consensus,
no initiative prospers,
and great personal ambitions
can easily vanish,
thank you very much